tony gonzalon 0-2 this post-season era
over nine
this his third start and with one out
nobody on here is randy arozarena the
breakout star of october here in 2020.
rosarena sends that one well hit out to
right field bets back and it's gone just
like that one nothing ray's and who else
randy a rosarina a first inning homer
for randy a rosarina number 10 of the
postseason it's one nothing ray electric
quick hands this guy
[Applause]
i just can't even tell you words can't
describe what he's done in the
postseason 27 years old 6'4 225 blake
snell yeah he's been awesome and really
has a chance to quiet the power of this
dodger lineup swinging a miss he struck
him out blake got it by him went away
struck him out swinging with a high
fastball at 97. two men away he's been
able to utilize all four of his pitches
and get swings and misses on all of them
he's struck at the side you can't do it
any better good start snell and reyes up
one after one in game six
rosarena at the plate caremeyer at
second choi at first one nothing race
two out second inning first pitch hung
on and missed strike three floro comes
in strikes out of rose arena on three
pitches dodgers get out of the mess so
here's austin barnes barnes hitting 318
with a homer and three runs bad at him
swinging a grounder toward third tough
in between hop for wendell he's got it
his off balance throw us down the line a
bit but troy able to get it and go tag
excellent decision on both ends for the
race wendell's only play at first and
then choi excellent job to come off the
bag and he had the ball in plenty of
time to force
austin barnes to
make an awkward move and he was out by a
lot well it's bets at the plate tying
run at second with two out
of this he struck him out went elevated
fastball there
and betts goes down swinging for the
second time
here tonight the dodgers leave their
first base runner so blake ready to go
lefty and lefty against corey seeger
here's a swing and a miss got him on a
slow
breaking ball and seeger is out on
strikes to start the fourth check swing
and he went around in a breaking ball
that zanino smothers and now gathers it
in and throws the first
take care of turner and that is
strikeout number eight so with two outs
and the base is empty here's max muncie
muncie tap her back toward the mountains
first time
he
struck him out blake snell strikes out
the side here on the fourth and he
continues to be outstanding victor
gonzalez pitching the sixth strikes out
swinging on the changeup and then well
margot coming up strikes out swinging a
94 mile an hour fastball there's two out
nobody on joey wendell coming up swung
on it miss strike three 95 mile an hour
fastball gonzalez strikes out the side
right now it's a one nothing raised lead
and blake getting ready to face
the lower part of the order the eight
nine and one guys and we'll see
if he's gonna give an opportunity
to work through this inning or if they
would bring anderson in the face the
right-handed hitting best but we've got
to get there first here's one into
center and the number nine man barnes is
a board
with one out in the sixth man you talk
about a short leash 73 pitches
two hits nine strikeouts snell can't
believe it a controversial decision no
doubt nick anderson is coming on to face
bench
[Music]
down the line hits the fence digging for
third is barnes they will hold him there
on a double by bets and the dodgers are
in business and a blink
so now the dodgers have second and third
here's seeger struck out twice by snell
and this
dodgers even the score at one pitch in
the dirt kicks past zanino
fetch goes to third
lead run 90 feet away
and who else would the dodgers went up
than corey seeger rounds into first and
coming home bets beats the throw with a
head first slide and the dodgers take a
two to one lead
bets one of the best base runners in all
of baseball breaks immediately on
contact and scores on seeger's fielder's
choice and now the dodgers are nine outs
from the world championship the move has
blown up only five pitches this inning
so far for urias and nine
as he's picked up in three outs and he's
got two out nobody on here in the eighth
come on and miss strike three
now the dodgers are three outs away
furious retires the side in order
vince will be leading it off to be
followed by seeger and turner o2 to bets
a hangar that's drilled to deep left
center field and gone
maybe the finishing touch
dodgers lead three to one inching closer
to the world series championship on a
home run by mookie
now the dodgers are one out away
call strike three
the dodgers win
finally the wait is over the dodgers are
the champions of 2020
in a year like no other where joy has
been so hard to come by tonight
tears of joy
let them flow